now one of the world's leading fashion
designers Tommy Hilfiger's in London
today to launch exhibitionism it's an
exhibition celebrating the Rolling
Stones is musical heritage featuring
over 500 rare artifacts Bloomberg
televisions - cranny caught up with
Tommy Hilfiger at his office in London
and began by asking him about the stones
is role in fashion well they created
rock and roll fashion I really believe
before that you could look at Little
Richard Elvis Presley Rock and Roll
stars coming from the states in the
early days but I think the stones took
that and evolved it or moved it to a
whole different place many of them are
female now and in the past all of them
were male so people could Beyonce and
Rihanna and Katy Perry if you look at
Miley Cyrus and and many of the the
female pop stars their iconic fashion
brands unto themselves I love what you
said is that we've moved from that male
dominance of the space of being the
vanguard for a brand to females if you
had to choose now between let's say Kim
Kardashian Adele and the Duchess of York
to put your female clothes on who do you
think it can really drive a brand but
three very different people I don't know
if the Duchess could drive a brand like
Kim could could but I would prefer to
dress the Duchess of York because I
think she has a certain class and Grace
sophistication but you know Kim has 69
million Instagram followers so she can
drive a fashion idea but it's a
difficult one because then you look at
others like Rihanna Beyonce or Gigi
Hadid I mean you look at models you look
at actresses from Hollywood you look at
musicians and
she who has the most Instagram followers
at 10 million up with more now have the
ability to drive a brand I mean here we
are that this is the evolution you've
seen every incarnation in fashion you've
designed it you're the vanguard but we
have Instagram with Twitter we've got
Facebook the medium of choice what do
you actually enjoy the most I mean look
at your Twitter account it's fantastic
but what is it drawers use is it
Instagram over twitter or over Facebook
what drives you that's all of the above
but Instagram for me is inspiring
because I'm a very visual person I like
seeing photographs and I like seeing a
lot of change a lot of evolution I don't
like to do well in the now I like to
look ahead and see what is coming up
rather than you know rather than looking
at the past or the present you know that
takes a moment yeah but then what next
I'm always looking at what next if I was
to say do you take me to the Future
paradigm take me to retail in the future
not debate but between being able to
touch and feel and to purchase online
for you what it what is that experience
you need all of the above it's called
omni-channel you have to be very
up-to-date with technology you have to
have great ecommerce you have to have
mobile app you have to have brick and
mortar you have to be really digitally
advanced I mean you need it all many
people like to touch and feel many
people like to buy from their phones in
China over 60% of the young people are
shopping by mobile now so it shows you
that in the future that may be the case
in the rest of the world that the
majority of the people will be shopping
by mobile app so we have to be either
ahead of the times or we have to be
right on point being right on point is
about taking from the runway which you
are about to do runway to my iPhone or
my Samsung and indeed into my closet and
that that's a revolution
well it's clicking by and it is being
driven by the
consumer the consumer is the ultimate
judge he and/or she want immediate
gratification they see something they
want to buy it and wear it that night or
the next day they don't want to wait six
months they don't want to wait three
months otherwise they'll go and buy it
from someone else or find it elsewhere